captain Ryan and Gerry Gerry and lion
Wow do-do-do-do-do-do Ryan Gerry and
Kent all right I know there's a yester
going on next door yeah what dick [ __ ]
you robber Audrey so guys today we're
gonna be watching the trailer for or Sin
City
- a dame to kill for whoo ah yes praise
the load Jesus we gonna be watching Sin
City - now it's only a 1 minute trailer
and if you saw a previous trailer
reaction cat wasn't in it but Jerry and
I had a lot to say but cat we hate our
thoughts on the last trailer what would
you say did you see the first Sin City
cat oh yeah it's definitely a good film
I really liked it you as an artist cat
who does things such as photography what
do you think about the visual design cat
did you know fun fact
Robert Rodriguez actually created that
technology really he did work a lot yeah
did a lot a screen test himself I think
when that movie came out a lot of people
had never seen a movie like it before so
completely agree with you cat well
that's one of the best like adaptations
of that kind of material ever like it's
a perfect visual cinematic
representation of those books actually
working on the film adaptation when they
just sell the rights you know you end up
with these movies that really have
nothing to do with their original vision
because it's the interpretation of the
director so I think it's nice when they
actually do collaborate with the person
who created the story in the first place
I don't know why you guys have been
taking so long with all these questions
you never know what's gonna be good
footage people he's gonna film it all
second trailer for Sin City dos sided
our is a fragile thing staring me up how
much I love you
Dwight is that you what I gotta do
she she was an angel she wishes it you
died
one of these days she'll pull the
trigger oh he's back [ __ ] just girl
Eva's good 11 to rocket sexy again as
always
you're already into this music to do
this movie's gonna rock not worried this
is gonna skyrocket like it just looks
like it's gonna deliver I hope so I mean
like it's long enough after and it seems
like even if it's not as strong as the
first one it'll still be yeah well
there's still some gonna be enough feel
pretty cute about and what I like about
Sin City yeah what robbery is really
done with the direction of it it doesn't
feel you know when you watch for
Rodriguez maybe they're like this feels
like a road this movie feels like its
own movie yeah I mean I mean it has a
lot of the qualities that rubber
Rodriguez movies have lots of Robert
Rodriguez movies have big casts of very
colorful characters and lots of
different things going on and they're
all a little bit choppy and like Sin
City has that with the very prevalent
Frank Miller's dial on top of it and
it's pretty easy to cast when you see
like how detailed they are man [ __ ] love
to adapt in comic book movie well I mean
it's like it was economic book you have
your storyboards already I would have
done I would a - Nightwing really yeah I
actually came up with a Batman r8 I
actually came up with a Batman 8 part
series and I think it would be a really
cool movie - I was gonna - one I would I
think that
Sandman yeah right can you imagine no no
the The Sandman comics Neil Gaiman that
should cut that out yeah well cut that
out so I don't look like a [ __ ] idiot
I think we're all in agreement on this
one looks badass I'm gonna see how I
feel and it was appropriately badass you
know and we've got the right cast
members I think it's gonna be good I'm
just fingers crossed you know yeah
fingers crossed sometimes that hurts
though Frank Miller should adapt
Garfield can you imagine the most deadly
cat no that'd be awesome most oppressed
cat comes in the house onie
he's got no brains but damn is he loyal
we're gonna get to the point here
straight to the point
Ross promotion cross promotion if you're
new the channel subscribe I like what
people get really pissed off at you for
not doing a shout out dude man yeah but
I talked about this with Sally's this
was on the 420 video yeah
so find this man okay this guy who got
mad at me he got mad saying like this
stupid short film where's my shoutout
and I was like I already gave you you
guys are great y'all deserve shoutouts
but I just feel that it's a little bit
like isn't a shout out of courtesy like
yes isn't it up p.m. of a privilege yeah
to get a shout out from us god damn you
people not like um we were all promised
one of these good I thought the agree
the contract is I subscribe and you say
my name though we're gonna shout out
anyway cuz you guys are awesome yes
Christoph you wanted a shout out that
out so was shouting out yes crystal yes
you like to jack off dual-screen when
you jack off when you come then you
suddenly cough you like to beat all
vents and blade what a badass name is
how many times that people call you like
bleed that sounds like the Afghanistan
version nobly yeah I'm sure that's what
I'm sure that's what he looks like
yeah if that's you if I can visit me
yeah know where to find me oh hey you
know who else please don't kill yourself
Cedric Martinez Cedric Martinez said he
would kill himself if we didn't get a
shout-out this is getting out of hand
this is getting scary the validation of
your life should not depend on whether
or not we've said your name out loud but
we love you for caring that much just
don't just don't jump give me your hand
please give me your hand don't jump
don't jump okay just reach Alex trust
the firefighter can I see you in glasses
damn you're cute what if I just try to
kiss you right now kid what would happen
what happened you like turn around like
Commissioner Gordon I begun
shows the realistic version where
whoever it is really is just like hiding
in a cupboard until they leave the room
wait for a time when he leaves wait does
the [ __ ] at night I wondered about the
clock out